do you ever think to yourself kevin
always no i always
i never share my thoughts with anybody
do you ever
think to yourself you know back in the
day you were
a struggling comic you know you were out
there yeah
working so hard just to get noticed
and um how much life is different now
well i think it's the same for both of
us you know we both came from
nothing
and we both came from you know i don't i
don't know
salt of the earth i don't think i came
from nothing my father had a very
talk show and i just inherited
my father had late night with conan
o'brien when it was on the radio and
then i just inherited it and i was like
oh father thank you
you know i've done this show more times
than annie richter has what are you
talking about
that's not funny it's true probably you
know what i will say
i don't know if you remember andy but i
think you were there at our first show
in 19 on september 13th 1993
uh you were still doing snl i think and
you came down and you sat on the floor
i came down and sat on the floor right
in front of you on the like below the
desk
i was on the desk at first but they said
no you got to get up
because you couldn't see the camera but
you were there it wasn't for the first
show i was sitting right there and
you're on the floor yeah on the floor
and i was watching
and i saw like every mistake right from
there
well this is good this has been a nice
shot i hope you've learned something
from our little chat here today
nothing i don't think i've ever learned
anything from you but
i've always enjoyed you i enjoy you very
much i really have a good time talking
to you seriously i really appreciated
everything you've offered me and
everybody else you brought on a lot of
young comics on your show
which they were really grateful i'd
always hear people talking uh comics
saying how
they did their first shot on conan and
that's going to stay with them for the
rest of their life
it's a nice feeling my first shot was
johnny carson
you know so that's what stayed with me
you're more of an afterthought
but still i appreciate you i'll take i
will take a backseat to johnny carson
any day now i'm going to be really
serious with you i think you did a great
job
i think you were one of the finest talk
show hosts out there because you were
different
and you did bring on a lot of people and
you you created a situation
especially for me where i felt
comfortable and i could try things
and be risky and um
and um and you had an amazing run and
you're not going to stop you're going to
be doing podcasts or whatever else
no seriously look at the end you said
wherever else like
landscaping no podcasting
you'll be doing something else a podcast
landscaping
i'm going to focus on landscaping uh
kevin
so nice of you to say that and sincerely
uh you're one of the all-time greats
and i'm so grateful that we're friends
after all these years i mean i've known
you after all these years i met you at
snl
and you were so nice to me then i think
i met you
in 1988 i met you in february of 1988
when i started in snl and you and dana
carvey walked in the room and right away
you were just a gem of a fellow to me
and you guy you came on with conan with
uh greg daniels
both harvard graduates all right nerdy
okay
kind of googly-eyed okay let's wrap this
up
the point is smelly go ahead wrap it up
uh
wonderful you said i had one of the
greatest talk shows of all time
insecure send on that note kevin i want
to thank you for being here
enough with the googly i never had
googly eyes oh i want to thank you for
having me here
let's not mix things up okay oh thank
you for you didn't have to have me here
no i did yeah you went out of your you
didn't go out of your way but you called
and texted every day
yes i had no choice you made you
harassed me go out of their way
you harassed me and i had to have you on
kevin nealon
first of all god bless i'm ending this
you hate to say goodbye don't you
goodbye that's not how you say goodbye
farewell you're not even looking at me
i'm not gonna look at you you're not
looking at me kevin you've missed you're
saying
goodbye kevin conan i love you i love
you and i love you
conan you're not looking at me